>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> SONYA LEE: My name is Sonya
Lee, a reference specialist
at the Korean Collection
at the library.
Really thank you for joining us
for the lecture, it's a history
of North Korea without
Kim LLsung possible?
Using the Library of Congress,
North Korean Collection
to rethink those Korean
history by Dr. Andre Schmid.
Dr. Andre Schmid is an
associate professor and Chair
of the Department of
East Asian studies
at the University of Toronto.
As historian of North Korea, he
has visited the library annually
for the North Korean Collection,
I don't know how many years,
about 10 years, something
like that, yeah.
So, he's well-known for his
award winning 2002 Book,
The "Korea Between Empire
1895 to 1919" published
by Columbia University Press.
I heard he currently he is
working on the book on North Korea.
Probably he can tell you
more about his book later on.
North Korea is often referred
to as a hermit kingdom,
due to the state enforced
isolation from outside word.
The library has over 10,000 items,
and then 274 journal
titles from North Korea.
This primary source provide the
users with a greater access to old
and new Korean materials for free.
One of the strength of
the Library of Congress is
that it contains the
biggest collection
of North Korean materials
published in particular
from the 1940s and 1950s.
Some of the records are not only
unique to outside of North Korea,
but are probably no longer
available in North Korea.
Our collection has be
vital to the scholars
and government officials trying
to understand the policies
relate to North Korea.
As attention high on the Korean
peninsula and the more scholars
and then [inaudible] to study North
Korea, our collection has continued
to provide a critical role
in leading this field.
The materials covers the reach and
comprehensive breadth of subject
but the major subject they use
recently are nuclear weapon,
of course, and nuclear program
in North Korea, the total import
and export statistics,
international relations, circus,
physical culture, and sports.
And cinema, even children's
literature.
Now, without further ado,
please give a big welcome
to Dr. Andre Schmid.
[ Applause ]
>> ANDRE SCHMID: Thank you for the
introduction, it's a true delight
to come to the Library of
Congress, As Sonya was mentioning,
I've been here many times
over the last few years,
spending many hours
with the collection.
I've got many friends in the
library, now and I wanted
to thank Dr. Shou [assumed spelling]
for inviting me to come back
to meet those old friends and
hopefully make some new ones.
I also wanted to thank the head of
the Korea Collection, Sonya Lee,
who over the last few years
has really put up with a lot
of pestering questions on my
part and irk some inquiries.
She's really opened up
this remarkable collection
that the library has
to me in ways that.
Interference from my microphone?
No. I'm not sure what that is.
Anyway, I've had the opportunity to
spend many hours in the collection
and it's been a lot of fun actually.
You don't usually associate North
Korea and fun in the same section.
Yet what I want to try and do today
with you today is talk a little bit
about the materials that I've
been using, give you a little bit
of a glimpse into the
1950s and 1960s.
And maybe take a step further
to suggest that the materials
in this library, combined
with some new
and different historical questions
can actually help us rethink some
of the fundamental assumptions
about the way we've thought
of North Korean history, which in
turn might help us rejig the ways we
think about North Korea today.
What I hope to do is to show you
how by reading everyday materials,
right, that people throughout North
Korea were reading on a daily basis,
published in Pomnyum, yet held
here in this great library,
you can possibly get beyond a type
of Cold War analytical dead end
in our histories, which tend
to over emphasize the power
of the Kim family and the power
of the North Korean state.
Something we generally
just don't talk about.
I'll try to do so by examining
through these newspapers,
these magazines and these
journals two crucial issues
in postwar North Korea,
namely population mobility,
the way people were moving
around, and urban consumption,
eventually getting to questions
of fashion, like on the slide.
This first slide I have up here.
I've titled my talk "Is
a history of North Korea
without Kim LLsung possible?
It might be reworded to ask why
are we so obsessed with Kim LLsung
and his two offspring Kim
Pyong-il and Kim Jong-il.
The answer would seem
to be obvious, right?
No other country has a single
family that has been able to amass
such extreme personal power over
the course of the twentieth century.
The stature of the Kim family
horrifies us, at the same time
as it gives us a type of
almost perverse pleasure.
A strange combination of observable
in everyday newspaper
and TV coverage.
We've seen it this week.
Right so it's typical to find in a
newspaper like "The Washington Post"
that writers and editors continually
invoke the inflamed rhetoric
of North Korea.
So, I was talking about
newspaper coverage in every day.
So, this notion that we
are both horrified and
yet at the same time take pleasure.
And we can see this in our
newspapers and the way editors
and writers regularly refer to the
inflamed rhetoric of North Korea.
Vocabulary like the seas
of fire, the running dogs
of imperialism are reproduced in our
newspapers both taking a pleasure
at the somewhat idiosyncratic
and bizarreness of the language.
At the same time as it is
almost a sense of horror
that there's a political culture
where such rhetoric
is taken seriously.
And with all that sound, I
forgot to show you my images.
So, our TVs are filled with images
originally [inaudible] and Pomnyum,
marching soldiers goose stepping
their way through downtown Pomnyum.
Most recently, with
missiles always overlooked
by portraits of the leader.
Mass games are constantly
on our TVs.
Again, playing on our
fears about North Korea.
But I think for my generation,
there's also a certain type
of nostalgia in these images.
A nostalgia for almost the
comforting days of the Cold War,
where this type of representation
of communism was so familiar
to people of my generation.
This leads to rather bizarre
website such as this one,
Kim Jong-un looking at things, which
is just a constant reproduction
of these on the spot
types of images.
I'm going to come back to this,
because I think what this image
does is it captures that as much
of these images certainly
have a place in reminding us
that North Korea is a
deeply repressive country.
These images also come
with a deep paradox.
If we scratch a little bit
deeper what we can see is
that the consequence
of our own fascination,
this strange combination of horror
and pleasure, is that such ways
of writing and visualizing North
Korea, actually reproduce a version
of the very Pomnyum propaganda
that we profess to be horrified by.
Indeed, our coverage
comes close to repeating
within our own analytical frameworks
and our own conceptual categories.
Some of the central tenants of
the North Korean personality cult.
This might seem to be
a strange thing to say
that we're being influenced
by North Korean propaganda.
Yet, nowhere is this more
clear than our own obsession
with the Kim family, which in
so many ways reproduces
the same obsession
about leadership that's
coming out of Pomnyum.
In our own histories just like
in North Korean histories,
Kim LLsung remains virtually
the sole historical figure.
The only agent of historical
action, decision and change.
I'll give you one quick example
on how this works itself out.
It's common for research on North
Korea to simply use a speech
of Kim LLsung as a historical source
to account what happened
on a certain issue.
Embedded in this type of
methodology is an assumption
that because we believe North
Korea is a totalitarian country,
there are no limits to the
personal rule of Kim LLsung.
What Kim says in any given speech
translates into action on the ground
with virtually no mediation.
Now, when we think about the
twentieth century more globally,
right, it's hard to imagine the
history of any other country
where such a methodology just
quote the leader is acceptable
or appropriate.
When it comes to North
Korean history, however,
what Kim says goes, as far
as history is concerned.
Moreover, there's no way out.
It's a dead-end.
We use high-level North
Korean propaganda, speeches,
declarations of party
congresses, the editorials
of the main newspaper,
legal statutes,
TV news broadcast,
etcetera as our sources.
All of which have the promotion
of the personality cult of one
of their priorities and that the key
assumption of Kim is at the center
of all this action and this is what
we reproduce in our own studies.
There's a circularity in this,
and I think we can find it
in a website like this right.
It's talking about Kim
Jong and looking at things.
But what's not in the title is
that we are looking
at the website, right.
We're constantly looking at the
leadership for what they're up to.
And a source like this
gives us no way of talking
about anything but the leadership.
So, just like Kim Jong and
looking at things, this website,
we can laugh at the
way Kim is exalted.
But we can't get outside
its bounds, right.
The pictures are still of Kim,
and we keep looking at them.
We roundly criticized the
personality cult and instead
of calling him the great
leader we might think of him
as the great despot right.
In other words, we flip the
normative assessment on its head.
Yet our criticism does not challenge
the fundamental narrative framework,
or offer alternative
sources of historical agency.
It's difficult to dislodge fixation
with the Kim family and at the risk
of overstating things,
perhaps it's time that we admit
that the greatest testament
to the power
of the personality cult is
it reaches out from Pomnyum
to influence our very own
histories of North Korea.
This type of circularity
and analytical dead-end was
once the case with Mow in China.
Was certainly the case with
Stalin and the Soviet Union,
and all the studies of Stalinism.
But it's been decades since
historians have moved beyond
such cartoonish understandings
of Stalin and Mow and,
with more complicated
understandings of the relationships
between leaders, states
and societies.
Yet not so with North
Korean history right.
Kim remains transcendent to a
history that he himself makes rather
than being a historical
figure who's made
by his arrow in this assumption.
This transcendence is arguably
the single most important feature
of the personality cult and we
see it in our own histories.
So, and this is a confession
or a self-criticism
in North Korean language
right it's not so much
that if you ask anybody is
Kim LLsung transcendent,
they're going to say yes.
But the framing of the history
puts them in such a position
that his relationship with
all other social forces is
such that he has that
exalted position.
This would seem to imply that my
answer to the question is a north,
is a history of North Korea
without Kim LLsung possible,
has got to be no, it's
not possible, right?
If Kim is history after all how
can there be a history without him.
But here's where I want
to say not so fast.
And I want to turn to the
materials of Library of Congress.
The materials contained within the
walls of this building allows us
to escape this type of
analytical predicament,
or dead-end, as I called it.
They do so by offering an
amazingly rich array of sources.
Sources that North Koreans
read in their everyday life,
from women's magazines that in
the 1950s and 1960s are talking
about unhappy housewives and all
the social problems around the home.
Much in the way that Betty Friedman
is talking about the problem
with no name in this country.
We can read workers newspapers to
find criticisms of fellow workers
who come into the factories
drunk and getting
into fights with their bosses right.
This is not a highly
disciplined workforce
if you take these stories
at face value.
From a worker magazine,
let's see if I can get here.
So, here's one women's magazines
that talks about unhappy housewives.
Here's a cartoon from a workers'
magazine that is using a cartoon
to sort of poke fun at the dizzying
speed of changes in the late 1950s.
You can see in the first frame
the workers going off to work
and when he comes home, there
have been so many houses built,
right that he can't find
where he lives right.
And we're all familiar with this
idea of the dizzying speed of change
and the fact that this is a
cartoon building on an understanding
of the humor of the reader right.
We know that this is a
widespread phenomenon.
We can read children and science
magazines, popular science magazine
that show us that the current crisis
on the peninsula has a cultural
history in the veneration
of nuclear technology; from
x-rays to weapons that are seen
as the pinnacle of
scientific achievement right.
And so very much more.
I've just listed a few of the
journals that are here I think
in her introduction, Sonya
said there were 247 or 274,
74 journals in the library
so the idea is often claimed
that we don't have sources to
study North Korea only holds
if you're interested in finding out
the inner secrets of the Kim family
or the machinations of the
highest reaches of the party.
For anyone interested in a
broader approach to history right,
the Library of Congress is this
rich playground of possibilities.
For my own period, the 1950s and
'60s in which I'm writing a book on,
I can't even come close
to reading all
that is available in
this building, right?
And frankly, I never thought
that would be the case.
I've never thought you'd be able
to tell me that there's more
than I can possibly as a primary
source to do North Korean history.
Now, where did all these
journals come from.
I don't know a lot about the
history of the collection
but it's an important
question to ask,
given that the United States
does not have foreign relations
with North Korea, how
did these come right.
As terrific as a librarian that
Sonya is, she can't just walk
into a bookstore in
Pomnyum and buy books.
You may notice on this particular
slide right on the missile head,
there are three initials
scrolled FDD,
that stands for the
Foreign Documents Division.
A section of the CIA that beginning
in the 1950s started acquiring
materials from around the world
for intelligence purposes.
This is one of those
classic Cold War projects,
productions of knowledge projects.
The sort of know your
enemy type of project
that begins acquiring
these magazines.
I don't know if this is the
source of all of the magazines
because they don't all have
those initials on them.
But you can also see another
clue, I think I missed a slide.
Yeah, I missed a slide, sorry.
So another clue is that
there's all these postal stamps.
I think in the display that
Sonya's created in the library,
you can see that because the United
States did not have direct relations
with North Korea, they had
to go through third parties
to acquire the materials.
So you see stamps from Prague,
from Warsaw, from Moscow,
I seen one from Hong Kong,
which was the most curious one.
So, clearly whoever was
purchasing these materials
in the foreign documents division
was approaching third-party
countries, sellers and
other socialist countries
to get these materials.
The results of the collection is
unrivaled in the United States.
In South Korea where national
security laws still restrict what we
can say or write about North Korea.
There's no equivalent
collection whatsoever.
Some of you may know
that the Ministry
of Unification has released
some materials that are
in the central library it's
called the [foreign word]
that doesn't come close
to reproducing what is
in this collection, especially
for the early periods.
The only library that possibly has
a collection rivals the Library
of Congress, is in Russia,
the National State Library,
the former Lenin Library, which
acted as a type of repository
for all the socialist world.
All these journals enable us
to do just really follow all
sorts of lines of inquiry.
I want to do sort of two quick
case studies for you today.
The first one is on
population movement.
Population movement, the mobility
of individuals has always
been a contentious issue,
on both sides of the
demilitarized zones.
Especially in years after the war.
It was used by both North and South
Korea in their propaganda battles
to attack the other
side's legitimacy.
You know the logic of
voting with your feet.
Ever since this time, the inability
of North Korean subjects to choose
where they lived, has served as one
of the key pieces in for example,
recent human rights writing
about the north to show the lack
of freedom in the north and the
repressive nature of its rule.
And this is certainly true.
From the North Koreans' perspective
however controlling the mobility
of individuals was
considered necessary
for central economic planning.
Only by knowing where everyone lived
could in theory, labor be allocated
to the most urgent
sectors of the economy.
And this was key to claiming
and all socialist economies
that they could be more efficient
than the capitalist counterparts.
Yet of course such control
was not so straightforward
and we can see this in the
specialty economic journals that are
in this library's collection.
The main one of which is called
Economic Research, Kim Jong-il.
Throughout the 1950s and 1960s, as
the country was recovering from war,
the economists writing this magazine
constantly noted the elusiveness
of the population.
And I want to just cite one
particular piece published in 1959
by an economist and Kim
en Jong [assumed spelling]
who is nobody special right?
He's just an economic planner
who is writing and he's writing
with a sense of frustration
at the inability
of central state institutions
to stop people from coming
to the cities from the countryside.
He complains that for that year
fully 30% of the new labor force
in the industrial and
transport sectors had come
from the countryside.
If we do the math, that means that
despite legal prohibitions more
than 114,000 workers came to
the cities from the countryside
against the plans of the party.
It's an incredibly large number.
But it's probably also
underestimated.
Because that's only two
sectors of the economy
and it doesn't include construction
which was the biggest one.
And it just counts workers,
it doesn't include
their families right.
So, we have hundreds of thousands
of people in this period moving
against the wishes of the party.
How did this happen, especially
given everything that we've come
to understand about
the power of the state.
The many resources of the
Library of Congress allow us
to piece together a
little bit of the story.
I'm going to give you a very quick
version of what that story is,
and it centers on the way North
Korean factories were organized,
right.
Something that probably you
didn't expect me to talk
about is factory organization.
But after the war, after the
devastating bombing that wiped
out most of the factories,
there was this desperate need
to heighten production and the party
did not have very much economic
expertise right.
Most of the party cadres are
coming from the peasantry.
And what they decide to do is they
decide to give those few people
that do have economic knowledge
control of factories, right.
It's partly a soviet system.
It's called the single
manager system.
But these people are given power to
sign contracts, to build housing,
and most importantly the local party
officials are being told do not
interfere with these
economic managers,
these factory managers, right.
Because we want above all else to
increase production and as part
of that goal they're given the right
to fire workers and to hire workers.
The problem is that at
this particular point
in North Korean history there's
an extreme labor shortage.
There's too much death
during the war right.
North Korean population
falls by something like 12
to 13% during the North Korean war,
during all of the Second World War,
the only country in Europe
that lost a bigger percentage
of its population is Poland, right.
So, it's affecting simply the
number of bodies that are available
to participate in the labor force.
There's still all sorts
of inefficiencies
in the way labor's been
allocated, but these managers are
under incredible pressure.
So, they do two things
in this context.
One is they begin poaching
workers from other factories.
Right? There's all sorts of
articles that criticize them
for what is called a
disorderly practice.
But there's no way to
stop them from doing this.
But most importantly, they move
to evade the controls that sought
to stem flows of people
from rural to urban areas.
They basically ignore central
directives and begin hiring people
that want to move to the cities.
So, if from the central
perspective, planner sought to deal
with depressing labor shortage
by trying to balance right
from a macro perspective
where labor would flow.
From that micro perspective,
from those managers
that have this political pressure
on them to increase production,
they don't care about
central attempts
to balance labor force
across the country.
They care about their immediate
need to increase production.
So, their short-term production
needs trumped the long-term national
plans of the center.
This just becomes one of the
way many places where we can see
that central plans for the economy
are undermined through tensions
with often the very different
interests of localities.
Now there are many other
factors of the story.
By 1962 right, so this is 9
years after the end of the war,
the state is still having
trouble making complete
population registers.
There are many complaints,
especially in the countryside.
People are just missing
from the registers
and this gives them the
ability to move to the cities
to leak out of the system.
The new construction of apartment
building created new types of spaces
that were actually very challenging
to put under surveillance,
allowing families often to double
up inside these apartment buildings.
Factory managers could also set
up their own housing to make space
for new urban arrivals
from the countryside.
All of these factors show
that by the mid-1960s,
when my research stops all
indications are that due
to these tensions between
national and local level planners
and factory managers and
the still limited abilities
of the state implement its
regulations, people were moving
into the cities outside the
designs of central planners.
State power clearly had its limits.
Moreover, people had their
own ideas of where to live,
and factory managers had
their own ideas of how
to go about hiring workers.
They worked in way to be allocated
workers from central state.
Whatever the regulations may have
been on the books they're willing
to take the risk and local
state institutions were unable
to stop them.
Here, we can see the analytical
dead-end I discussed earlier working
itself out in a slightly
different form.
Our conventional understanding
of population as static,
unable to move was derived from
reading Kim LLsung's speeches
from the legal statutes that
are on the book and combined
with our Cold War assumptions
about totalitarian power.
This led us to believe
that Kim's words
and the laws were thoroughly
implement.
But this certainly wasn't the case.
And as I tried to show the danger
when doing North Korean research is
that we take intentions as outcomes,
right, a basic historical falsie.
Indeed, even that frustrated
1959 economist
that I mentioned earlier
suggested as much.
He wrote, and this was one of the
more shocking things that I read
when I was first starting
off my research.
He goes and says Kim LLsung's
words have been simply ignored.
I never though I'd see the
written in North Korea.
But you do find all sorts
of indications of that type.
In this economist frustrations
then we can see that as much
as he would've liked people
to follow the words of
Kim LLsung's speech.
They didn't.
There was a much more
complicated socioeconomic
and cultural history shaping the
demographics of the peninsula.
One that can't be captured through
notions of totalitarianism alone,
or simply reading through
these high-level sources.
Let me shift to my
second case study now.
I want to give you a really
quick history of consumption.
Most historians of consumption
under state socialism
have long recognized a
fundamental ambivalence.
On the one hand socialism's promise
of a mass utopia included a
certain assurance of a level
of material comfort
for the population right
through consumption.
On the other hand, Stalinist
economic models invested
in heavy industry, ensuring
an emphasis on those sectors
of the economy, the
underserved the very consumption
that was promised of the population.
And this was no different
in North Korea right.
Where similar decisions
about the priorities
and economic investment
were made after the war.
The ambivalence became manifest not
just at top-level policy positions,
but at the personal
level of everyday life.
In large number of pieces of advice
literature that are available to us
in this library, that
sought to teach people how
to be good socialists so to speak.
There was this wide-ranging
discussion about labor
and participation reconstruction,
about production.
Yet, the issue of consumption, how
should a good socialists consume,
was for the most part reduced
to a single simple point.
The importance of saving
and not wasting.
An emphasis on frugality on
self-help all these were promoted
to act as a type of key
to accelerating the growing
material prosperity of the country.
This emphasis on frugality in turn
led to a type of unease or anxiety
in the way that consumption came
to be represented in the press,
in the media, in the
early years after the war.
And sort of interesting
in this anxiety.
Early reporting about the
construction and use of apartments
for example, captures
this sense of ambivalence.
Starting in 1954 well
I forgot this slides.
So, this slide is the
classic type of cartoon
that we talked about saving with.
The first one, [foreign
word] means saving, right?
So, you've got a happy family with
the worker who saved properly.
The second one is about alcoholism,
the worker who's spending all
of his money on booze and look
what happens to his family.
This this type of cartoon.
This type of discourse is
through the media in these years.
And much of this discourse
focused on apartments.
Since 1954, the party began
to make massive investments
in workers apartment buildings,
transforming cityscapes
of the peninsula, as
I hinted at earlier.
Yet, despite all the celebration
of how these apartments represented
the success of the revolution,
the press was much more comfortable
about treating these buildings
in terms of the construction
rather than their inhabitation.
Thus, you get this
type of photograph.
It's about the monumentality
of the building.
The pictures are generally
from outside.
When photographers did
venture into apartments,
the photos are almost always
cropped, closely onto a family
in a genre that might be
called the happy family photo
without really allowing
the camera to pan
across the space of the apartment.
There's a certain reticence
to show the apartment
as a space of consumption.
And indeed, there's a
critique at this time,
as we can see in this cartoon
here there's sort of a fear
that women would get too
comfortable inside the apartments
and not be interested
in going out to work.
And here's one where we can see
at the top a woman is sleeping in,
and she's doing her makeup
and her sort of comfort
in his apartment space that
makes her late taking her kid.
All right complaining at the end.
So again, there's this
reticence to show the apartment
as a space of consumption.
Here I'm going to make a bit
of a jump and jump to the 1960s
where you get a shift, and
the shift is quite stunning,
I only saw it last time I was here
at the Library of Congress
in November.
There are two specific journals
called [foreign words], New Life,
that begin in 1963, and I'm
not quite sure why it's 1963.
Suddenly offering long
and many articles
of what we would today
call lifestyle coverage.
As one article in this period
asked, where does a rooms sense
of harmonious beauty or taste of
cultural refinement come from.
That's not easy to
answer in a few words.
And indeed, there were many
words in these pages later
to try and talk about this.
That type of question where it's
invoking cultural refinement,
harmonious beauty, would
just had no presence
in the press just a
few years earlier.
So, these articles talked about how
to arrange the furniture
in one's home right.
They began to discuss how to
hang pictures on the wall.
Should you have vertical
versus horizontal pictures.
Should you have sunlight
or curtains.
Clearly the preference for pictures
were landscapes there's discussions
about what color is best for what
type of room or even color charts
for people to choose from.
By this point we get no sense
of reticence or ill at ease.
In fact, when you look at these type
of pictures you can begin to see
that the camera is taking a step
back and it's beginning to show more
about the objects through which
people lived their everyday life.
Right? So, here's one chockablock
would not have met the design
criteria of any article
I've ever read
in North Korean presses too jammed
with tables and plants, right.
Here's another one and
here this is featuring two
of the main consumer
items from this period,
the radio in the sewing machine.
So, very much a well-off family.
Right? Anybody know what's in
the middle of the table there?
Goldfish. This goes as well for
the way furniture is discussed.
You can see these ones.
There's absolutely no people.
You can see the painting.
You can see that there's no Kim
LLsung portrait on the wall.
Again, a very different sensibility
of what could have been
discussed in an earlier period.
This transfers over
to fashions as well.
In particular, women's clothing.
I'm not going to talk about this,
because I'm running out of time,
but I just want to show you some
of these images from this period.
And we can see that there begins in
the 1960s new forms of femininity
that have a lot to do
with new forms of clothing
that aren't the typical here's one
of the color charts for clothing.
So we have these new forms of
femininity that don't fit into what
until this point fashion had largely
been either your work uniform
or you know the [foreign word] what
in South Korea is called the hanbok,
the traditional Korean dress.
There are all sorts of questions
that we can ask about these types
of images, these types
of consumption, right.
We can ask legitimately how many
people were actually consuming
like this, right?
We don't have good answers for.
We can also ask what did it mean
that this was being
publicly discussed right.
This isn't a type of
secret form of consumption
that only high party officials
are doing behind closed doors.
These are pictures that are
circulating in magazines
that have tens of thousands,
some of them have
over 100,000 copies being printed.
Just like in this country, even
if you can't afford everything
that you see in the magazine
you can consume the images right
and the promise of
what this might mean
about the future, about
possibilities.
We can ask what does
this consumption mean
about postwar class formations
and uneven distribution of goods.
It's also possible that we wonder
whether there were certain groups
that taking advantage of that
ambivalence towards consumption
that I spoke of earlier pushed
the promise of material comfort
to create a space to speak
of consumption in new ways.
This would put these consumers, or
these writers about consumption,
together with the factory
managers and the urban migrants,
that I spoke about in my earlier
case study as people whose behavior
in these important rounds
moves beyond the type
of top-down directives of
the leadership in the party.
In other words, another
location of historical agency.
However one chooses to
interpret this consumption,
one thing is clear is if we're to
read Kim's speeches the resolutions
of party congresses or even the
main newspaper, the [foreign word],
right we would miss out completely
on the significant economic
and cultural changes.
So, the problem I described earlier
of taking intentions as outcomes,
we can add the further problem
of simply not looking in places
where we can locate
socioeconomic and cultural changes.
Ones that are not being unilaterally
produced by the leadership
or the party, but which
in fact contribute
to shaping the possibilities of
postwar politics in North Korea.
So, let me conclude by doing
what a historian should never do,
make a few comments about the
current situation in North Korea.
Most observers know that since the
early 1990s there have been a lot
of changes afoot in North Korea.
Some of the indications of these
changes commentators often speak
about, what population mobility.
People are moving around
in lots of new ways.
New forms of consumption, where
women's fashions are often talked
about as are the new
style of apartments
that are going up in city.
There are many more, I just wanted
to highlight that the three areas
that I sort of talked about in
this talk, are referred to today
in order to track changes.
These changes are often read as
indicating a decline in the capacity
of the state to rule
the country right.
People are doing stuff that
the state doesn't want to.
Some commentators go so far
as to predict the imminent
collapse of North Korea.
We know that going back
to the Clinton years
at least this assumption
even shaped certain parts
of American policy
towards the north.
Now as a historian, I'm not in the
business of making predictions other
than knowing that if you
continue over decades
to predict the collapse, you
eventually might be right.
I can't help but notice that
these predictions of the demise
of the North Korean state
often take as a background
against which they measure these
changes the very cartoonish
understanding of North Korean
history that have attempted to draw
out that concentric totalitarian no
alternative historical agency type
of history.
Yet if you consider the history of
population movement and consumption
to try to offer you today,
we can see that there's always
been a much more complicated
and fluid history in the
relationship between the Kim family,
the different segments and levels
of the state, and the population.
If we escape the type of Cold War
era style histories of North Korea,
then the context of the many changes
that are being remarked
upon today begins to shift.
And so, the meaning of today's
changes also begins to shift.
Always there have been limits
on state power in North Korea.
The state has always had to
adjust to changes in social
and economic forces, and one of
the virtues of this collection
at the Library of Congress is that
it allows us actually to begin
to try and explore some of these
other areas of historical agency.
Some of the social, economic,
cultural, and gendered forces
that shape the history
with which the party,
with which the Kim family is
actually having to deal with.
And I'll conclude my remarks there
and I'd be happy to
take any questions.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
Yes, in the back there please?
Could you tell me your name, maybe?
[ Inaudible Audience Question ]
Right, it's a great question, right.
Because especially in the '50s
and the 1960s North
Korea sees itself firmly
within a socialist word.
There is all sorts of circulations
of movies and magazines.
North Koreans are participating
in conferences throughout
the eastern bloc.
And I think the trick to
answering your question is partly
which eastern European, or which
other socialist country you're
comparing with because
there's an enormous variety
of these questions
within socialist blocks.
So, one place I would start would be
for example, the design of housing.
So, one of the things we could
find in the library here is
that there are architecture journals
where we can see all the types
of designs of apartments that are
being constructed in North Korea.
And even all sorts of models that
were never actually constructed.
We see that somebody, I don't think
there was a single decision made
on this, but there is no
communal housing in North Korea.
It's all designed for the
single nuclear family.
It's two rooms, a kitchen,
a bathroom,
and you can shut the
apartment door, right?
So, unlike in China, if that's our
comparison, it's right at this point
in China of course that communal
housing is being developed.
Very different from the
situation in North Korea.
So, in China the assumption
that this architecture design could
help breakdown, or weaken the bonds
of the family because it's
considered to be the bastion
of futile values or
Confucian values, right?
In North Korea, and
I think it's partly
because of the colonial experience
in North Korea, there is an attempt
to use architecture to firm up
the nuclear family actually.
If I were then to look at
the designs with what's going
on in the Soviet Union
at this period,
we know that Khrushchev
right at this moment is part
of his anti-Stalinist drive is
actually using everyday life design
and material comfort
as one of the ways
of criticizing the Stalinist era
and opening up new possibilities
for the Soviet population.
What we see going on in North
Korea is more in tune with that.
So, you see the circulation
of housing designs,
or these exhibitions.
But, there's an important
distinction is that the Soviet Union
in its cities it's much
wealthier than North Korea, right?
So, in terms of the material
culture, the objects,
I think there's no
comparison, and even less though
with east Germany, right?
so, you're right that it's
important to see North Korea
in that broader socialist
world context.
But we have to also be
careful that there's a lot
of variety within that context.
I've always been curious
what's going
on in Cuba at this particular time.
I don't know that but, yes?
[ Inaudible Audience Question ]
So, you know my sense is that there
aren't as many links with China
as there are with the eastern bloc.
Partly, you have to remember
that the North Koreans set
up their country in 1945 four
years before the revolution, right?
And so, there's actually this sense
that we got there first in a way.
Through the 1950s, so let me address
your question by maybe talking
about fashion, women's fashion.
My understanding of most of the
literature on the People's Republic
of China is that scholars emphasize
how after the revolution there was
that sort of de-feminization
of women in China,
but for the most part dress
becomes more masculine orientation.
There's less emphasis on femininity.
North Korea, that never happens.
If anything, what happens
after the declaration
of equality this would
have been 1946,
North Korea is the first country
in Asia to declare the equality
of the two genders, right?
And while you have that druidical
influence, emphasis on equality,
you've got all sorts of
other ways of speaking
about femininity, naturalizing
femininity.
So, in North Korea for
example, there's an emphasis
on the way women speak,
speech is promoted,
there are specific feminine ways
to speak, which is an important way
of naturalizing gender
difference, which becomes important
for the segregation of labor, right?
There's all sorts of complications
when we begin naturalizing
that distinction.
So, unlike with China the issue
with the way femininity
is being promoted,
actually becomes very important
for understanding the
way the economy works,
and understanding actually
political power.
I don't think you can understand the
direction of the personality goes
without understanding some of these
fundamental assumptions about gender
that developed in the 1950s.
My understanding is that that's
very different from what goes
on in China at that time.
Any other questions?
Yes sir?
[ Inaudible Audience Question ]
That's the hardest,
single hardest thing
for me to try to get at, right?
Because you're getting through a
style of rhetoric that is influenced
by the party, and you know there's
this upbeat, we're all happy type
of rhetoric which we know
is produced by the party.
And you can't really write
outside of that, right?
So, if you want to
grumble, you have to do it
in very careful ways in the press.
You certainly can't do it
in the high-level press.
So, everybody knows
the [inaudible] right?
You read that and the form of
rhetoric is really standardized,
right, it's the political discourse
of political study sessions
that everybody writes about.
You shift your focus and you go
down to the newspaper called the
[inaudible] one character difference
it's put out by one
of the workers' union.
And the tone of writing
is completely different.
The types of stories are
completely different.
So, one of the pieces
that fascinated me is there's
all these worker criticisms
of each other, right?
And here you get maybe not a sense
of the mood toward
the regime, right?
That's the type of thing that
you see kind of expressed
in the opposition, but you get a
sense of the tumult of precarity,
or tumultuousness of precarity.
It's these types of materials where
you can read about street parties
that get completely out of hand
because everybody's drunk, right?
Somebody writes in a letter to
the editor and goes this isn't,
you know proper communist morality.
These people don't have a
proper education, right?
The truth of it is there was
just this party on the street
that work the guy up
and he's complaining,
he's invoking the party's
rhetoric to complain
about these workers, right?
So, in that we get a sense
of the variety of life.
We get a sense of a lot of the
social and economic problems.
So, I'll give you one other example,
I printed out in one of the slides,
alcoholism is something
that's talked about, right?
So, there's one of the first
factories opening coming
on after the war that
Kim Jong beer factory.
Okay, yet throughout the press,
right, there's all these complaints
about workers coming
to work drunk, right?
About spending too much money.
And one of the, in fact one of
the ways that you can get a sense
that the material standards
of living are going up,
especially since we don't always
trust North Korean statistics,
is you can see the
social commentary,
bout workers in their dormitories.
And there's all sorts of problems
with gambling and drinking.
And the reason it's offered,
right sort of the indirect
way of getting the question.
The reason this is explained is
because workers have gotten too much
money and there's not enough pride.
But it's quite amazing, so basically
you know they're keeping busy
by gambling and drinking because
they've got too much money.
It's an interesting way of getting
at the material life question
in the end from this period.
So, it's you know these types
of materials I think
give us a better sense
of the complex social
relations at the time.
At the very time that these workers
are talking, and giving us a sense
of the rambunctiousness
on the streets, right,
you read party history that
comes out just after this.
And you know everything is about
the leader, and unity of the party,
the harmoniousness of the; that's
just not true, that's fantasy right?
But those party histories
are being written in part
because that's what
they're trying to promote.
The history has to be
seen itself as a tool
to promoting what doesn't exist.
All right, and so these types
of materials give us a chance
to not just read those top-level
materials, but get a sense
of the messiness at this period.
But I can't answer the
question, what is the mood
of the population towards the
party or toward Kim LLsung.
I will say that in the 1950s
and early 1960s, right?
As much as we hear about Kim
LLsung in the headlines and stuff,
again looking into the type
of understanding we have today
of personality cult just
didn't exist then in the 1960s.
So, while I'm up working
on that personality cult,
we're actually missing is a very
careful history of how that looks
in south and up, and
the unevenness of it.
So, you can find, there's
some children's journals
in the collections, by
about 1960 you can see
that for some reason the children
and the youth journals began
printing Kim LLsung's name
in a bigger type.
Other newspapers and journals don't.
Right? There's this unevenness.
So, my question, I see that
again, it's not something I study,
my question then is you
know some of these features
of the personality cult that
we've come to know and expect.
How did they develop, if
there's this type of unevenness
between different media
outlets, it doesn't appear
that it was a central order, that
said everybody shall now write
with a bigger script for
Kim LLsung's name, right?
So, the question is are people then,
for their own political purposes
at that time taking certain
initiatives to participate
in what they see is
a political direction
that some people are pushing, right?
I don't know what the answer is,
it's not what I've been studying
in particular, but you can see
that that unevenness is something
that needs to be talked about
in order to have a better sense
of the complexities, even around
the rise of the personality cult.
So, the way, if I were to go back
to this sort of argument I'm trying
to make in my talk is, I don't think
we can understand the personality
without having a better
understanding of the diversity
of social and cultural experience
in the 1950s and the 1960s
because the personality
cult comes out of that
and depends upon the
forms of discourse
that existed in that period, right?
So, by simply focusing on the
outcome, we miss out on a lot.
Oh, sorry, can I ask here
there's another question, sorry.
[ Inaudible Audience Question ]
Sure. Sure.
So, that's a huge issue,
thank you for asking it.
And it even goes back to the
first question that I was asked,
a different form of comparison.
So, you know South Korea's the other
North Korean's constantly you can't
read a newspaper without reading
reportage about South Korea
in the North Korean press.
What's a little bit different
from the German example,
which was raised earlier is
that, you know by the end
of the 1950s you can
argue that urban areas
in North Korea were
materially much better off
than many people in South Korea.
So, the housing that we see
being built is happening
in North Korea before it
happens in South Korea, right?
So, in the German case,
there's always this sense
of East Germany not being
adequate enough and trying
to catch up with the west, right?
In North Korea, there's
not this sense of catching
up with South Korea at all, if
anything there's this trumpeting,
like these types of photographs
from apartment buildings I
show are about our successes.
And if I had wanted to
pursue this as a theme,
I would have shown you
they have all sorts
of newspaper articles
reprinted from South Korea.
It's one of the big
surprises that I found out.
So, in South Korea in the 1950s
and 1960s, there was actually sort
of a conservative critique of
the South Korean government
about the sort of disarray
of creating morals in
South Korea, right?
Comes from a conservative position.
Ironically, that conservative
critique of South Korea in things
like the [inaudible] and the
like, was used in North Korea,
it gave North Korea fuel, right
to criticize South Korea
in their own press.
They quote stories from
the South Korean press.
They use photographs from
They pay really close attention to
the media in South Korea in the sort
of battle for legitimacy, you
could write and entire book just
on the ways, the images
of South Korea are used
in that type of competition.
A little bit like what goes on
between PRC and Taiwan too, right?
[ Inaudible Audience Question ]
Sure, so that would be typical of
South Korean arguments about Marxism
and being anti-national, right, it's
sort of a betrayal of the tradition,
yet what's also forgotten is
that you look at the North Korean
in 1950s and 1960s and their
historians are publishing all sorts
of books about the length of
Korean history and they talk
about Korean history in the ways
that eventually South Korean
historians move towards.
So, the emphasis on
[inaudible] and the north.
Some of you know Korean history
know that there's a lot of talk
about these [inaudible] right?
In 1955 they're already
publishing one
of the key scholars complete
works in North Korea,
well before they're
available in South Korea.
So, they're not making the
argument that we're better Koreans
than the south so much in
terms of invoking history.
They make that claim based on
economics and they make the claim
on the continued American
military presence in South Korea,
which is a whole other issue, right?
>> SONYA LEE: And we have
to close it and [inaudible].
So, actually Dr. Andre Schmid will
be at the [inaudible] to lunch.
And he'll be here until Thursday.
So, you can ask more
questions and then come back
to our reading room, yeah.
Thank you for the sharing.
[ Applause ]
And then, actually we have a
display of North Korean materials
at the reading room,
Dr. Schmid mentioned
about stamped item,
the FDD, we have that.
And you can see the cartoon actually
showing 1955 North Korea was opposed
the nuclear weapons.
Yeah, it's in, I happen to find
this so you can check there.
And then especially
check the display case
because there is a really rare,
I'm not saying really old,
but rare materials from before
or until the Korean War 1950.
It's kind of deteriorating material.
That's why we have protect that.
It's really valuable materials.
So, you can check that.
Thank you for coming all of that,
enjoy all of you in joining us.
And it was a pleasure
to see all of you, okay.
Bye.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.com